first segment left our friends over at
duracell have challenged us to think
about the games we played the most in
2015 those games that forced us to not
go to the bathroom and get extra snacks
that surround myself in Pringles and
whatnot I can then go to the bathroom in
the Pringles exactly i crumble right
Duracell quantum batteries into your
controller as you keep on playing and I
got my three friends here next week
we're Mike em hard year and Peter brand
talk about the games they played the
most this year I've also got a bunch of
great input from you guys hashtag
duracell sweeps if you want to get the
game you played the most in on the
discussion and stay tuned because at the
end of this segment we're going to give
you details and how to win the top ten
games that came out this year as decided
by us what are they I didn't it I want
to do but I didn't I tell you anyway the
first stop before we get to the user
suggestions an x-ray Korea hi first game
the game you played the most in 2015 so
I didn't play this game the most in
terms of I would sit down a marathon it
but it was the game that I came back
consistently to every day blood-borne
okay so when I had like a crappy day I
would come home and I put in blog burn
and I would kill some things if I had
like a really bummer day I'd go home and
like play blood-borne if I was angry at
someone I'd come home and I blows one
place like what yeah well I got over
nicely bloodwine I just like a big I
played it I finished it and then I came
back and I did a new game plus and I
have been playing it sort of a little
bit like over the past couple months and
like on like a friday night when like
all my friends are out partying and I'm
an old person so I like to be home in
bed and like 9pm like you know what i'm
gonna summon him I'm gonna make some tea
and I'm gonna play blood-borne yeah so I
just like blog 14 hours and I sort of
found a lot of I felt like I was
improving as I was playing it and it's
the one game i played this year that
really made me feel like I was
accomplishing something cuz i was just
overcoming all of this like gruesome
crappy beasts hmm so i just i sort of
settled into it like a nice comfy couch
excellent and a lot of people in the
office of have enjoyed maybe it's in the
top ten games who knows what we do what
we can tell you a BB on gamespot com
soon enough just going into the tweets
here here's a great one that i know a
lot of people have to say
because I know a lot of people
especially in production are going to
agree with this John Gotti Oh says the
game I played the most this year was
destiny the taken King Oh what they
gonna see rocket League yeah I was in
the memory yeah yeah a lot of Destiny
fans here in the office technica
obviously was a big thing for them as
well really improved that game Mike you
like those games but that's not what you
picked it's not what I picked what I
picked afro sent no all right the
witcher 3 um I didn't until you know I
read Kevin's review and I saw it getting
really positive reviews across the board
I plan on playing it anyway despite the
fact that I really play the first two
yeah but as soon as I got into it this
it's unique fantasy setting and like
it's got its own weird creatures it's
got its own very vivid world like
convincing characters it was one of the
first RPGs in a while I've played where
I wasn't completing quests just for
experience or new gear I was completing
questions because I felt like they were
worthwhile and it told a great
overarching story in the main quests had
you know a great structure you build up
to this one point where everybody
thought it was the end yes and there was
like eight hours after that and that was
also really good ending yeah especially
was last 2-3 hours yeah crazy definitely
and but just all these like smaller side
stories that you like on the periphery
of the game itself that you come across
and these characters you meet arrange it
from like funny to really sad to really
just kind of ominous and a lot of points
and I kept playing it because I went
back in knowing there was something i
was gonna find that was gonna push me
through another you know half hour hour
and a half two hours that I'm just
really enjoying despite the fact that I
might not even be getting experience
more it how many hours do you think you
played um I'd say close to at sea in the
90s okay cool yeah because I and then
hearts of stone came out so I went back
to play that and then I played another
like 10 hours of the game itself and
then now with them wah blood and wine
yeah it's coming next year let's just
double the size of hearts of stone
entirely new area I'm sure I'll put at
least another 30 into it at least we've
even keeps on giving yeah I've got some
great tweets coming in here hashtag
duracell sweeps and this might be my
favorite so far gadget file says 569
hours and counting clicker heroes no 69
like that cookie clicker man it's like
those clicker games you just let him go
just go on holidays vacationer was great
tell you how many hours you played I'm
sure student has a timer probably
shouldn't know yeah I think cookie
clicker does all the nice to plate up
another one a great here at mama bear
coach 68 didn't get that 69 say 3,000
hours in gta5 that seems a bitter day no
they come out on pc this year so tech
hands Peter brand what does the game you
played the most 3,000 hours I know
that's a bit thicker games man you know
I think I put the most hours into
Xenoblade Chronicles X because it's a
very long game that I had to finish but
the game that I elected to play the most
was the phantom pain hmm I think I
replayed about 50 hours for the review
I've probably put in close to 80 I'd say
at this point I it you know I don't know
I feel like I'm always repeating myself
when I talk about this game the the
control you have over snake it's it's
cumbersome at first because the controls
are a little bit complicated but once it
clicks it is like it was surreal how
smooth everything felt to me like I
didn't feel as much I was like
controlling a video game character as I
was willing him to do my bidding without
much thought like it just it felt so
good to do all the things that he could
do and then like bringing all these
vehicles and you know the world like
like ninety-nine percent of it you can
interact with in a way that that is
meaningful to how you approach a mission
but you know what what really really got
me into the game was some of the amazing
like I hate to say it but the visuals
yeah cinematography the the melodrama
that came with the cutscenes I mean I'm
gonna play this game anyway ones I've to
review it but two because I like Metal
Gear but it's astounding that the
opening to this game is mmm and I and I
hate to do it but you compared to
something like The Witcher the opening
yeah I'll take a nap like this thing
wasn't it was it was crazy and it just
kept on going with the story stuff after
the fact I had all these great things to
unlock everyone in the world has sort of
adjusted to my strategies they've gotten
used to my tactics so I have to adjust
and constantly evolve to be effective
and the things I didn't unlock them
became harder to unlock and the game
just kept challenging me in new ways
it's always a good sign of a game where
you want to repeat missions and see what
it looks like a different way yeah and I
Donald all this game forces you sort of
to do it
later on in the game like I certainly
enjoyed doing that a lot when I was
playing this like yeah if you took
yourself out of the linearity of the
experience you were just like this is a
stealth challenge right there are some
really great stuff in there that it made
you do this game feels great wherever is
playing just as determined to carry this
dude a full center bus Colton or GTFO
another great game I mentioned here at
James Aukerman says fallout 4 currently
210 hours and Jesus yeah that's that's
pretty good that's like how much I put
into three total I think oh really yeah
yeah that's a lot that's a game I feel
like I'm gonna be playing for a lot of
2060 as well they can play definitely 70
hours as well yeah reviewed a lot of
long video games this year beating yeah
xana blades metal gear fall out which is
the only one you need to dive into all
your Christmas break yeah I haven't
plays as much that as I'd like and
that's probably the game that i would
pick in terms of tyne I think I'm if i
add up my xbox one and pc i think i'm a
rain to 200 hours I'm which you're now
if they don't but love like that but
since you already talked about it I
would have to go for rocket League just
purely out of the fact that it's a game
that we've played so much and they posed
like a game that we have made our best
video this year yeah we played it so
much in the office marrakech sick ass
trail talk [ __ ] skip that part it has a
bunch of DLC stuff that he kept adding
to it so you kept one to come back they
just out of the ice hockey stuff as well
I think like yesterday and so the office
is playing I'd like it's game a plate
here in the office played at home with
with people and also just online with
randoms like it's a game it's just
super-fun to keep going back to over and
over and over again I wonder if it's
gonna be asleep cuz we've talked about a
lot of games via the hashtag duracell
sweeps and also what we said here on the
couch it'll be interesting to see how
many of those games made it into our top
10 list yeah and what order they might
be in as well but no matter what the
order you have a chance of winning all
ten of what we have the side of the best
games of 2015 at your platform of choice
unless we can't give it to you ah I was
bad to say something god that was so so
close unless it's not on a different
platform let's say add to do that all
you have to do is go to a link on
gamespot com which should hope they
okay so calm port / your cell sweeps go
in there fell a little farm and you've
chance to win what we decided with the
top 10 games of 2015 make sure you check
back gamespot all this week and next to
find out what our top 25 list is as well
so the 14 15 games that won't kill you
won't get if you enter this competition
and folks thanks for coming on today